Oh
if you look at the educational system
it's doing about thirty to forty to
fifty percent better with females than
males so College enrollments are
overwhelmingly more female than male and
the question is why is that there is
some feeling that the introduction of a
kind of women studies cast of characters
has tended to make males feel somewhat
out of sorts or not fully wanted and in
my decline of males book i described
males as having been born with a male
original sin that is if you're boring a
guy you have to work it off you have to
express your feelings you have to do all
those things that will be oku wrong with
the current sexual fashions which can't
be much is mo ish can't be too draconian
ly male can't watch football as much you
have to articulate a different path no
that's relatively trivial I'm not trying
to make a point about it but the fact is
that in the school system we see boys
don't work well and overall and there's
a political question if taxpayer-funded
entity is producing a better result for
one part of the population than the
other hey that's not fair and be it
constitutes the social problem so for
example I discovered that this was after
i wrote the decline in males that four
out of five kids expelled from
kindergarten our boys now my first
question is how the hell do you get
expelled from kindergarten but the
second is why this differentiation and
then we see for example in the use of
drugs to drug kids that ninety percent
of the victims of Ritalin or boys and i
know a case at the moment of woman has
got a child it speaks three languages is
in a school where most of the kids speak
one and the child is very bouncy and
very active and very energetic and the
mother was told that
apps the child could be brought to a
medical practitioner for an evaluation
that word was used and you can be
certain that they're thinking let's drug
the kid let's calm him down with ritalin
or some other substance and that's
that's very serious because we don't
know what the long-term impactive of
those powerful drugs might be on a small
organism so the issue of what happens to
males i think is now resurfacing in a in
an interesting way and i think it offers
us the opportunity to begin to re view
the matter to begin with the basic
biology to begin with the notion of
humans as primates and to assume that
male primates and female primates will
act differently in many cases the same
but also in many cases differently and
we should understand that better and
with with warmth and not hostility and
so the male original sin problem I think
has to be avoided because it's the
results are poor 50 years of women's
studies for example and I'm not singling
out women's studies I think it's a
general issue 50 years of that since the
first program was established in 1970
has yielded a system which is very
biased it appears functionally against
males and after all who wants that when
my book the decline of males came out
the warmest response i had was from the
mothers of boys who rode and called and
whatever to say you have no idea what
goes on in the schools like my son has
his hand up all the time nobody
recognizes him because they're supposed
to favor girls well that may be an
exaggeration but that was the response i
had and i thought that was very
interesting
I'm not sure that they're feminizing I
think they have impacts and we don't
know for sure what those impacts are we
know some impact the kid is quieter them
maybe learns more learns better on the
other hand we have very good reason
historically to be very suspicious of
drugs that cause behavioral changes
because the changes they cause are never
the ones that are explicitly indicated
on the package and so one wants to be
very very careful and I would if I were
a medical practitioner which I'm not and
I don't have any expertise in the matter
I would be very very hesitant to drug
kid who's three because we have no idea
what the long-term implications might be
on that child's development a boy or
girl but since most of the victims of
these drugs are boys we have to assume
that essentially they're being feminized
in the sense that their behavior is
supposed to become more female like
oh sure I've been told by parents that
their children under these drugs are
much better off in school however I was
talking with a French doctor who teaches
at the University of Paris medical
school and he said that now this was 45
years ago that in all of France there
are forty six hundred people kids taking
ritalin that is probably as many as
there are in high school in a local
suburb they regard and this drug as a
highly suspicious drug very very
powerful and it's on the restricted list
along with cocaine heroin and all of
that so nobody can get it in this
country school nurses just handed out
and so I think we have sold ourselves a
very shabby bill of goods which may cost
us a lot of human competence and years
to come